et puis stephen bronfman va présenter ce
soir son projet de stade de baseball
dans le cadre des audiences de l'office
de consultation publique de montréal
l'homme d'affaires souhaite acquérir
possiblement en partenariat avec le
développeur immobilier devine qu un
terrain de près d'un million de pieds
carrés à proximité du bassin pire en
plus du stade le secteur pour accueillir
des bureaux des tours à logements départ
qu' une école plusieurs organismes
communautaires s'opposent à ce projet et
réclament des logements sociaux qui sont
rares près du centre ville
andré richelieu et professeur à l'école
des sciences de gestion bonsoir sont si
friands
monsieur richelieu c'est quand même tout
une coïncidence aujourd'hui que de voir
disparaître
roger taillibert qui a qui est
l'architecte du stade olympique est de
voir quelques heures plus tard stephen
bronfman annoncé un nouveau stade de
baseball
est-ce que ce stade olympique a mal
vieilli du coup les jeux c'est un
monument qui est une icône en fait de
montréal vous l'avez dit emblématique
grandiose on pourrait même dire
pharaonique et ce n'est sans doute pas
un projet qu'on pourrait reproduire
aujourd'hui tout simplement parce que
au-delà des dépassements de coûts c'est
un projet qui était beaucoup trop
grandiose pour les besoins de montréal
d'ailleurs selon moi il a été sous
utilisés on aurait pu faire beaucoup
plus on a récupéré une partie pour en
faire le biodôme par exemple mais dans
la tour on avait même prévu de faire des
gymnases par exemple ce qui n'a jamais
été le cas pour favoriser la pratique
sportive donc l'héritage socio
économique de ce stade et je dirais
aussi déficitaire que le coût de la
facture astronomique qui associé à la
construction rénovation et réparation du
stade et de son toit en trop et donc
quelles leçons doit-on tirer de cela et
du parc olympique en vue des prochains
projets et je pense bien sûr au stade de
france
vous avez mentionné plusieurs points en
introduction et aujourd'hui si vous
regardez ce qui se fait bien dans le
monde par exemple singapour avec le
singapore sportifs arabes ou même à
moscou avec le vitib irina qui servit
et entre autres à la coupe du monde de
soccer l'an dernier je crois bien
on essaie de construire des projets où
le stade est en fait un point d'ancrage
de retour de ce stade vous développer
différents projets avec différentes
activités différentes vocations
donc ça peut aider tours à bureaux ça
peut être des logements ça peut être des
commerces ça peut être aussi des
logements sociaux
et si par exemple un montréal il ya un
besoin pour ce genre de vocation entre
autres autour du bassin peel c'est
quelque chose qu'il faudra écouter
attentivement parce qu'on a besoin de
l'appui de ces groupes communautaires
pour que ce genre de grands projets
aboutissent qu'il y ait ou non une
équipe de baseball
le projet entre autres de logements
communautaires mais aussi de
développement de revitalisation du
quartier doit se faire en concertation
avec les gens qui vivent parce qu'en
bout de ligne c'est pas juste les
amateurs de baseball qui doivent
profiter d'un stade où les amateurs de
hockey on parlait des canadiens un peu
plus tôt c'est aussi les gens qui vivent
à l'année longue dans ce quartier ce
dieu en avril grille d'inter pied c'est
ce qu'on appelle des mesures
structurelles c'est un projet c'est là
que les projets deviennent structurants
et qu'on laisse un héritage
socio-économique avec permettez-moi le
langage mais c'est ce qu'on utilise dans
les études que je réalise un capital
social horizontale c'est à dire que les
bénéfices peuvent profiter à une grande
partie de la population et que ses
bénéfices dure dans le temps
non seulement pour un événement où
quelques matchs puisque au baseball ya
81 matchs à supposer aussi que l'équipe
va du veux jouer tous ses matchs à
montréal et on n'a pas de moitié les
clichés attend pas ça c'est le débat
mais qu'il y ait cette vision de laisser
un héritage pas juste parce que il ya
une opportunité de baseball mais parce
que dans le développement de montréal
on estime qu'il ya une priorité et que
ce projet peut s'intégrer dont peut
devenir structurant pour laisser cet
héritage socio-économique et
permettez-moi le jargon qu'on utilise
mais effectivement ce capital horizontal
qui est effectivement très important
pour qu'il soit accepté par la société
sinon il y aura de la résistance et on
aura pas d' équipe de base-ball et donc
l'équipe en question c'est l'équipe des
rays de tampa bay
qui sont en séries éliminatoires
présentement c'est l'équipe que veut
monsieur brafman à moitié officiellement
peut être au complet
éventuellement est ce que le projet
qu'il semble vouloir présenter puis on
aura toutes les confirmations ce soir
est un projet justement qui s'incarne
bien comme vous présenter dans le
quartier dans l'économie dans la société
il y a un début il ya des prémices mais
si on entend la communauté mais
d'ailleurs je regardais un petit peu ce
qui s'écrivait sur ce projet avant
l'entrée en scène aujourd'hui pour me
préparer
il y a des points d'interrogation pas
seulement est ce que l'équipe va revenir
ou non mais est-ce qu'on se sert de ce
projet pourrait effectivement répondre à
des besoins qui vont vers vraiment
satisfaire des besoins importants pour
les montréalais et qui vont durer dans
le temps qu ronces et impacts socio
économique au delà du sport donc
autrement dit dans une perspective
stratégique si la mairesse nous
regardent aujourd'hui le sport est
devenu un levier de développement socio
économique c'est-à-dire qu'on se sert du
sport que ce soit d'infrastructures
sportives ou d'événements sportifs pour
développer des infrastructures qu'on
appelle périphérique entre des logements
sociaux des tours à bureaux des routes
le métro puisqu'on en parle aussi à
montréal qu'on n'aurait pas fait
autrement
mais le sport n'est plus une fin en soi
c'est vraiment un levier pour justement
développer ce tissu socio-économique
dans une ville ou dans un pays c'est la
société tout à fait tout à fait c'est ça
que sont devenus les stades où les
infrastructures sportives mais aussi des
grands événements sportifs et je parlais
de singapour par exemple je parle aussi
de la russie qu'on a beaucoup critiqué
mais il ya certaines choses que la
russie a bien fait notamment avec son
stade à moscou qui a respecté le
patrimoine qui s'est intégrée dans un
parc et le parc petrowski en banlieue de
moscou par exemple et qui hantent
contraste total par exemple avec ce que
fait le qatar et des stades
je dirais même pharaonique qui
ressemblerait étrangement à notre stade
olympique dont on parlait et qui est un
héritage de monsieur taïder donc
aujourd'hui ce sont des projets de
société
le sport les infrastructures sportives d
vié pour le développement socio
économique et le bien-être de la
population qui vit à l'année longue
dans cette ville où dans ce pays on
verra si monsieur bronfman entend très
bien cela andré richelieu merci pour ses
exploits des plaisirs